I missed this and did not have time to
talk about it until today
um this guy from Newsmax Rob Murphy who
is on the bandwagon attacking me on
Twitter uh over the last few days for
the controversy about the Nashville
shooting he interviewed failed former
president Donald Trump and Trump said
something bizarre Donald Trump said that
he appointed Ron DeSantis governor now
that didn't happen
it simply didn't happen there's there's
no way in which that could even be
remotely interpreted as accurate listen
to this strangeness about Rhonda sandis
he told Eric bowling last night uh that
he thinks the New York Alvin Bragg probe
is a political Stunt by George Soros he
also said he would not consider being
your vice president in 2024. I want to
ask was there was that ever an option
for you
no I never thought of it I think that we
have a lot of great people in the
Republican party I never thought of it
but uh you know some people every once
in a while mention it but that's about
it no I think that would be a very
unlikely Alliance but you know look I
appointed him he was failing badly in
the Box he was out of politics he was
going to be out of politics and I
endorsed him and he went from a very
small number to a very high number you
you appointed him What on earth does
that mean is does Trump mean that his
endorsement was such a lifesaver to
desanctus that it was like an
appointment Trump saying I endorse you
is almost as good as Trump's saying I
appoint you the governor of Florida very
very strange Trump then talking about
January 6th and he says he made
beautiful statements despite the fact
that he incited a riot I'm president of
the United States I made beautiful
statements if you look at my statements
I wish you could read them off to your
viewers which by the way I see you're
doing very well so I'm proud of you rob
yeah but I wish you could read them off
to the viewers but I called for peace I
called for all of these different things
on numerous occasions yes he also used
the words fight or fighting more than 20
times and quite literally incited a
riotous mob a trump asked about
um DeSantis Moore and he went after
DeSantis for his covet numbers which is
super into interesting I'll explain why
in a moment you both but that's that's
Politics as we move into primary season
here I want to ask you
up and you know I don't like saying this
about another Republican but you have to
you know everyone thought he did greater
than covet but if you look at the list
he did poorly uncovered he was in the
numbers the same numbers as New York a
little bit worse than New York he's bad
on education bad on covet bad on many
different things that people don't know
about so you know now you know what
Trump is right it's just funny because
Florida to Republicans is either The
Shining Beacon of freedom and liberty
in a sea of wokeness when it's
convenient or it's sort of like not that
great
if you want to criticize Ron DeSantis
and I have made this case before
Florida's per capita Cova death rate is
very so so it's not the worst and it's
not the best it's just like kind of
mediocre that's true Trump's right
education in Florida it's not very good
it's not as bad as in Arkansas or
Mississippi but it's not very good
either it's not Connecticut or New York
or Massachusetts or Maine so Trump
actually is right here it's just funny
that they're only they're only willing
to say this stuff we all know
when it's convenient for them which
shouldn't come as a shock Trump was
asked about his choice to hold that
rally over the weekend in Waco Texas on
the 30th anniversary of the Waco Siege
he completely ignores the question about
this rally tomorrow in Waco Texas you're
holding a massive rally it's going to be
televised here on Newsmax of course next
month marks 30 years though since that
deadly government Siege of the Branch
Davidian compound there we've got the
mainstream media right now accusing you
of quote stoking the fires of Waco with
this visit and with that location I just
wanted to get your thoughts on that and
and what people can expect from the
rally tomorrow yeah well I hear there's
thousands of people I mean we're going
to have you know many many tens of
thousands the line is already miles long
trying to get in and I I don't leave
until tomorrow late afternoon and we're
going to have a great time in Waco we're
gonna have a great time in Texas I want
Texas by a lot two times as you know and
we have tremendous support in Texas we
have a lot of the congressmen are coming
a lot of the great people in politics
are coming and uh most importantly the
people of Texas are going we're going to
have it's going to be a very big rally
we're just now starting our rallies
because people love the rallies and
we're just now starting the rallies and
this will be about the first one that
we've done we've done interior things
but this is the first major rally and
and I think they're bigger than ever
before that I really see it okay so
again Trump not answering the actual
question about the fact that he's in
Waco and all of the imagery and all of
the insanity of doing that and then
lastly hear Trump going after his former
lawyer and friend of the David packman
show Michael Cohen it was just the
opposite and then on top
this whole thing in exactly the opposite
way it which really showed that cone was
lying he was lying badly but he's known
for that you know he's sort of a con man
and again he was a lawyer who
represented other people and uh you're
supposed to have a certain allegiance to
a client you know nowadays that doesn't
mean so much with all of these uh
prosecutors out there that just so Trump
bemoaning that even his own lawyers
aren't loyal to him really deranged
interview
celebrated by Newsmax there will be much
more of this to come
and I predict it is going to get much
much worse from the things that Trump
has been posting to Troth Central I
think this sort of insanity is only
going to get worse